you can't turn off the economy like like
flipping a switch I will be almost
touching elbow that somebody goes next
to me because it would be so crowded
everybody pass it's Friday May 29th 2020
and here's quick-take trap of the
pandemic this week one in every four US
restaurants will go out of business
due to the corona virus and the effects
of just one closure can set off a chain
of losses for all those involved I
didn't realize that just one restaurant
like ours could that have that card
ripple fan
this is the first time ever we turn off
the light we keep the light on all the
time for 18 years
it probably had to go way back into
January in Wuhan China when they locked
out the whole city the whole country
their surrender people stopped few like
if they go to the Chinese restaurant
they might get in fact it - but I mean
we are here in the United States we're
not in China but that's what people
think so we got affected back then not
just now April's the whole manner
April's we lost everything
most of the visas would have broccoli
one way or the other and I realized that
the dysphoria come all the way from
Mexico that day a few days before April
first we have to call them and say I'm
so sorry qualities that the last time we
order until we reopen no he called me I
was telling me that they're closing it
was like it's not April Fool's but we
are closing he prefers like Wow
why it's very close May was buzz of
course I wasn't shocked
eighty percent of our sales are
restaurants so one restaurants closed
down they had to get rid of all of their
supplies when they had to get rid of
their supplies we did too but we got
stuck with ours and then when we got
stuck the farms gotten stuck so imagine
of 20,000 pounds of broccoli that week
only 5,000 pounds moved right you're
still stuck with 75% of what's left so
we had to throw out dumpster loads it
was hard and that it's not just for
broccoli it's for all the other
vegetables and meats as well so as a
farm they need to produce and they need
to keep up with what we're selling so
they have it the hardest if they don't
farm three months ahead of time they're
not gonna have crop for us when we when
we make an order I got that call from
SPCA we gotta cancel the shipment it was
already dispatched to load on a truck
we are the actual farmer and grower of
vegetables in Mexico our cache proudly
is broccoli
and we never fathomed pay all the
restaurants in the country are going to
have to basically shudder their doors we
mount up having to dunk or donate almost
half a million pounds of product
unfortunately we also found out the
limitations there that the local food
banks couldn't take even half of that
product must because they were already
so full their coolers couldn't take
anymore they didn't have enough people
to distribute so we had good food that
we had to literally throw in dumpsters
because there was no channel to get that
product to people who needed it and then
if you go back one step further from
there to our fields in Mexico again you
know peak seasonality we're shipping up
to 3 million pounds of broccoli per week
we had to cut it down to about a million
pounds when the truck is not flow
obviously you're gonna get paid less a
lot of truckers they they own their
trucks right so you're making payments
to $3,000 a month for a truck more than
than a mortgage a lot of this pros come
in the border from Mexico 50% all our
loads come from them from fortune
growers initially you know we packed
them to the max to make maximize profit
so when a broker or shipper doesn't have
enough product to fill up your trailer
basically we're just running the trucks
at a loss there's no way you can make a
living like this you can't turn off the
economy like like flipping a switch and
then two months later turn back on and
expect everything to be normal it is a
chain reaction you take one piece of
that puzzle and then everything falls
apart how's it hurt
[Music]
people who are affected [ __ ] the turnip
virus in school and it makes its way
into the wastewater infrastructure then
wastewater treatment plants collect
samples and send them to us our first
results were gathered from a large
metropolitan region and what we were
able to see via sewage testing is that
there were up to 100,000 people infected
with corona virus in that catchment area
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Sarah Parcak and I'm a
market reporter with Bloomberg News by
now all 50 states in America have begun
the reopening process in some form
allowing businesses to reopen in some
way or another and to many this is
allowing some optimism to creep back
this was front and center last weekend
over the Memorial Day holiday and I'm
sure by now many of you have seen images
of pool parties beaches crowds out and
about and this can cause some different
feelings ranging the spectrum to some
this raises concern that too many people
in one spot raises the odds of yet
another Kovan nineteen ways a second
wave as it has been called and that
could lead to more human suffering or
even another closing of a common it's
just causing this to last longer however
there are others at the other end of the
spectrum that actually view this in a
positive light and that is because the
way they see this is they say it's proof
that there is pent-up demand consumers
have been holed up for so long in their
homes and as soon as they are allowed to
get out and about and spend they will do
that and that means that the economic
recovery can be sharper can be swifter
it can be faster this past week even
Jamie Dimon the CEO of JP Morgan came
out and said that he sees
pretty good odds of a fairly rapid
recovery so how the consumer does act as
economies reopen is really front and
center right now when we're seeing this
optimism feed into the stock market you
have the S&P 500 around 3,000 you have
the Dow hanging out around 25,000 and
some professional investors are asking
and we're on the cusp of yet another
breakout to the upside and it's evident
in the contours the underline of the
market as well because as we've
discussed before the areas of the market
that are most closely intertwined with
not just the economy but also the
reopening process are now performing
well that's smaller companies that might
have a higher risk of bankruptcy of
going under also what's called the value
investing style where people investor
you keeper companies a lot of times they
are very much tied to the way that the
economy goes a lot of bank stocks are
value stocks also just those that really
do stand to benefit most from a
reopening Cruise Lines
Airlines Delta has been performing well
United Airlines also Royal Caribbean
Carnival the stocks that had really been
brutally hit during the sell-off but on
the flip side the companies that benefit
from stay-at-home orders or that have in
the stock market at least and you've
seen it through their financial numbers
like Amazon Netflix for example while
all of a sudden they're not beating the
market anymore
they are lagging so many people thinking
about the three opening process is it a
true positive for the market right now
many investors would say yes but still
many risks are out and about top of that
list is the potential second wave of the
corona virus also bankruptcy risk is
still out there
so some risks is still keep in mind as
you do see optimism making its way out
about
[Music]
[Music]
nobody is social distancing nobody is
wearing a mask except maybe me today is
day one after Prime Minister Shinzo Abe
a lifted the nationwide lockdown or here
Tokyo in Shibuya I'm headed to shakyas
scramble from the busiest places I think
in all of Tokyo
all right we're gonna cross so before
the lockdown started at a typical
shibuya day I would be almost touching
elbows if somebody goes next to me
because it was
crowded now we are underground Shibuya
station Japan in terms of the number of
Cova 19 cases it was the best among the
g7 countries the w-h-o just praised your
pants saying the handling of the corona
virus outbreak here was a success so
Japan did lift its state of emergency
declaration nationwide Tokyo itself
still isn't back to normal
governor Eureka quake has said that
Tokyo will reopen in three stages and so
it will be more of a gradual reopening
of the city below department stores in
Tokyo are mega food stores where mass
social distance and please shop and a
few numbers as possible everything looks
like they're packaged pretty well which
i think is good for this coronavirus era
I'm a little bit wary of buying tomatoes
that are outed open like this because
anybody can touch these I think from now
on I might be buying more of these that
are already wrapped in plastic
I wonder if single-use plastics will go
up
yeah so that is Tokyo's thanks for
sticking with me on my walk
[Music]
reports of anti-asian hate crime
incidents have dramatically increased
during the corona virus pandemic meet
the Neighborhood Watch Group patrolling
the streets of New York City to help
keep people safe Asians in this city
we're suffering the same hardships we're
under the same stress but we do not look
for anybody to scapegoat
ever since hope at 19 there's been a lot
of anti Asian sentiment in the country
or there's also a lot of harassment we
have cases of verbal abuse there even
physical attacks in New York City you
know we want to let people know that we
want to tolerate this kind of behavior
in Chinatown or the nearby areas
Chinatown block watch is a very simple
concept of neighbors keep an eye out for
neighbors
[Music]
we're here the witness we're here to
document pattern of harassment
not everyone New York City is a very
tolerant city but there are people out
there they look at what's on the blame
and unfairly the races are pushing this
agenda that we need to playing the
Chinese or playing the Asians for this
watching these videos of Ages being
attacked
you know all over the country and all
over the world gave us the sense that it
just wasn't very safe to come out as a
matter of fact a lot of the older people
in Chinatown also didn't feel safe but a
lot of times are living alone they have
to go out and get their own shopping
beginning with the group was to
alleviate that Chinese have always been
known to evolve out their daily lives
try to stay under the radar but now we
get stepped on too often that's why we
have this trance out block watch
we've been president on the street here
for over a month now you're on the
police right three weeks ago there was
maybe 15 to 20% of the force or job sick
with this Kovach we are not replacing
them at all right we are at your eyes on
the ground for them so we see something
we're gonna call and report it but we're
visible deterrent so they get is
reassuring to the residents of the
community who are online the buy
groceries is to be assuring that the
businesses that are open black hair and
have the mass on they're gonna look at
me like they have the deceit in me we
don't know what gonna happen to us in
the neighborhood of calyx you say has
the pole is also like on the petrol and
also like the neighborhood the community
they kind of keep an eye on it
an incident on Grant Street a couple
weeks ago her customers didn't wanna
wear face masks or maybe they didn't
understand they didn't read the Chinese
sign hosted a misunderstanding escalates
quite quickly especially when there's a
language barrier there's a need for
estimating information the business
owners as they slowly open up we're
we're not just not patrolling anymore
we've been passing out flyers in English
and Chinese well we know what she's done
it they keep labeling how do
oh how terrible
so we're trying to decimate information
as we get it that that we think is you
know important for the community a
notices of government grants for small
business cash grants forgivable loans
even maybe unemployment whatever a lot
of people don't have access to English
media or they don't understand English
well this actually started with me and
two other guys
so I put in on social media and you know
a lot of the residents my friends that
live in the area they wanted to get
involved so now we have over 20 people
we're not all Chinese we have a very
diverse group here it's the racism
that's going on and again not just this
community but in this country in this
world is something that we should all
address and improve because if not like
who will I was wearing a mask in early
March and someone did threaten me it's a
very important thing making sure that
would advocating for these people who
are being victimized where people are
different ethnicities backgrounds but
we're all coming together to fight
xenophobia and racism
so nowhere has been hit harder by the
coronavirus than here in New York City
but even as hospitalizations drop it's
hard not to think back to what went so
wrong
so drew you're taking a look at this
what were some of the missteps that you
found I think if you look back at the
rise and peak of New York City's
epidemic you have this mix of bad luck
bad structural circumstance and what we
knew about the virus at the time some of
the things that we were told to do based
on what we knew about the virus at the
time we're just wrong I mean we have the
mayor saying right the subways you could
only get this from someone coughing
directly on you and I think now we know
that that's certainly not true if you
look at how New York City is built it's
tons of shared spaces subways buses
trains elevators apartment buildings
with lots of people living in dense
spaces then if you look at how the virus
got here Wow the travel hauled from
China shut down a lot of the import of
cases from there there was a raging
outbreak starting in Italy and Europe
and we were bringing in travelers from
Europe by the hundreds of thousands in
the weeks before travel was shut off
there so New York was seated pretty
heavily from multiple different places
by the time this outbreak burst into the
public eye it had already been pretty
widely spread in the community and had
become much more difficult to control at
that point we're still one of the few
cities that are still pretty much on a
virus lockdown can you walk us through
how the response here compares to other
major cities I think there were a number
of steps that were taken that were
crucial in the decision-making process
to look at if you look at an outbreak
and how it goes you see an initial
period where you have a few cases called
the seeding period then you move into an
acceleration phase where you see the
exponential growth of cases that New
York had and then you move into the peak
period and now we're on the downslope
New York moved to lockdown the city much
later in that and the result of that was
that the peak was much much higher than
it might have been with
actually we can look back with hindsight
and say oh you should have locked things
down three weeks earlier but that might
not have been politically possible it
might not have been possible from a
public policy standpoint I think it's
quite difficult to actually make them in
the beginnings of an outbreak that we
didn't know how bad it would get in the
United States are we here in New York
City more equipped to handle a second
wave and I wonder if there are other
densely populated cities around the
globe that have taken this time to
really equip themselves and prepare for
that potential second wave I think the
answer is to a certain extent yes and no
we spoke with one of the CDC's senior
infectious disease personnel who made
the very good point that an outbreak
like this isn't like a global earthquake
that we all feel at once it's City and
regional based and it moves from place
to place we're still in the early phases
of this and New York had the misfortune
of being hit first in the biggest way of
the major US cities New York and other
places still have the structural problem
where you have lots of density you don't
have a vaccine some fatigue about social
distancing measures and so there's more
knowledge about what to do but there's
still some significant vulnerabilities
in New York and elsewhere around the
globe to this virus some people have
compared what we've done here to Sweden
or South Korea South Korea is an
interesting example because they've put
in place such a rigorous testing program
that instead of having one big peak of
cases they've really been playing
whack-a-mole
over and over where they have little
outbreaks pop up they like anywhere else
are gonna be dealing with this for a
long time testing doesn't solve your
disease problem it just makes it a
little bit easier to manage when we talk
about managing an outbreak like this
that's an example of what you talk about
they still have rules that they have to
follow and they're still doing quite a
bit in response to it just but what
they're doing looks a little more
precise and a little less blunt than
what's happened in some other places
[Music]
[Music]
every time we get on a plane air traffic
controllers are there to keep us safe
and do their best to get us places on
time well the challenges they're facing
during the corona virus pandemic it may
be nothing new it's not as bad as in
2008 but they are doing exactly the same
mistakes
[Music]
it started in nineteen that all of a
sudden oh we don't have enough
controllers because we didn't recruit
and then the traffic went up
dramatically with increases of fifteen
percent per year what we see today
already is now it's the same thing then
what happened in the crisis of 2008 at
the time then we were of course still
maintaining let's say eighty-five
percent of the traffic then the managers
european-wide said Oh eighty-five
percent so we don't need new controllers
but everyone said hey hey hey this will
pick up of course and in 2019 that was
one of the highest traffic pictures
which we have seen
but then the controllers were missing
let's say in January he still it we were
faced with a big problem of not having
enough controllers when we need them
because the traffic picture over the
year is of course different than January
you have less traffic than you have most
probably in July and September there is
a so called performance and charging
scheme in place since 2012 which
foresees a kind of ague crisis when the
traffic is 10% higher than what was
foreseen for year X then this money has
to be given back from the service
providers to the allies where these the
passengers are saving money or the
airlines are boosting their their
profits in the situation where the
traffic drops dramatically like it did
after 2008 9 when we had the first
crisis then
have a so-called costless sharing
mechanism which is working to the other
side as we are supposed to keep the a
space open and even if there would be no
flight but to keep the a space open you
need a roughly 50% of the staff
available otherwise you can't maintain
this so a service provider has
permanently running costs but with what
was proposed here they have no income
anymore if it will happen a real impact
on the future when I started we were
five people on one sector today we are
two and the traffic when I started was
200,000 flights a year
today we in master's we have 1.9 million
so who a one way or the other
will be a very costly exercise
[Music]
we've got blood tests we've got nasal
swabs all kinds of ways to detect the
corona virus and now we can add to that
mix poop specifically wastewater there's
a company called bio bot that's
analyzing this wastewater to try to look
for the corona virus and they found that
in a lot of cases the virus is much more
widespread than the more conventional
test would show so let's head off to
Massachusetts to interview the founders
of bio bot would you two mind
introducing to yourselves maybe Mariana
first my name is Nisha Gailey and I am
co-founder and president at biobot
analytics your company the two of you
have come up with a pretty unique way to
look at corona virus maybe you're
talking about about sewage coming from
from different parts of the country
right correct we can detect the virus in
wastewater because people who are
infected shed the virus in school and it
makes its way into the wastewater
infrastructure then wastewater treatment
plants collect samples and send them to
us right now why what has a pro bono
campaign and we are testing about 10
percent of the u.s. population on a
weekly basis versus about one percent of
the u.s. population that is being tested
through the clinics and the results that
you've already seen a pretty striking
yeah our first results were gathered
from a large metropolitan region in
Massachusetts and on the day that the
samples were collected there were about
450 confirmed clinical cases in that
community and what we were able to see
via sewage testing is that there were up
to 100
thousand people infected with corona
virus in that catchment area so just
dramatically more than what the regular
test was showing yeah exactly
there's actually a large asymptomatic
population likely or individuals who
have very mild symptoms and so they're
not seeking out testing however they're
captured and represented in sewage data
and so we're seeing them in our tests
and I know you get a 50 milliliter
sample how how is that representative of
an entire city's population so treatment
Maps it can sample the wastewater as it
comes into the treatment plant
constantly to 24 hours to current even
we get representation from every toilet
flush that went through that community
and then from that aggregate sample they
are taking a small adequate and sending
that to us and using that sample we
measured how much virus was present in
the wastewater with a technique called
qpcr the grapes for the genetic
signature of the virus okay
and you would already have this company
up and running to kind of look for other
what other diseases in wastewater
already correct we originally were
working with the opioid epidemic
measuring the concentration of different
types of prescription opioids in
wastewater to create better programs
it's not the most glamorous job maybe
what what dream
this field I really grew up with
hardship so I've always been passionate
about creating technologies that help
with equity and bring better resources
to people who need it and the beauty of
looking at wastewater as a diagnostic is
that everybody has a voice in the sewer
you don't need to have the money to go
to the doctor you don't need to have
medical insurance as long as your house
is connected to the wastewater your
information is counted and we can bring
that to create better programming what's
your vision for how this plays out over
the the coming years yeah our vision he
said one day
this technology will be basic
infrastructure for every city and town
worldwide so we will be constantly
screening our populations for new
outbreaks of the novel coronavirus and
in the snacks like week two weeks three
weeks I mean they're just gonna be more
and more data coming out obviously from
the work you're doing all of the
facilities that we're working with
really believe that weekly testing is
very important one of the biggest
questions facing government and
decision-makers right now is how and
when can we start to safely open up our
cities again and our economies again and
testing at scale is one of the most
critical things in order to help us get
there and we're not gonna be able to
test every single individual that's just
not realistic
and so this type of testing can really
be helpful in making these types of
decisions of scaling back quarantine
style measures or social distancing and
so all of the facilities that we're
working with are sending us weekly
samples we're giving weekly data back to
them and that were we're excited to see
how that progresses
[Music]
alright that wraps things up first this
week thanks for watching but remember
you can get all of your coronavirus news
from quick-take 24/7 on twitter
instagram facebook and youtube and for a
daily recap of the day's top stories
subscribe to your newsletter thanks for
watching we'll see you next week
[Music]
you